[Musique]
merci Jacques-Marie Bardin dièse d'être
avec nous vous êtes sismologue vous
allez nous aider aussi à comprendre ce
qui s'est passé bien entendu merci
d'être là Pascal vous vous étiez donc à
Marrakech ce week-end comme on l'a dit
vous avez observer l'étendue des dégâts
vous avez envoyé quelques vidéos
regardez
Pascal on nous avait envoyé de
nombreuses vidéos qu'on va regarder
également tout à l'heure c'est vrai que
là-bas c'est fou on a vu les images
d'ici c'était incroyable vous
racontez-nous ce que vous avez fait là
c'est dans le quartier du meylard
exactement qui a été le plus touché à
Marrakech il faut savoir que dans ce
quartier les Marocains qui vivent déjà
dans des conditions qui sont extrêmement
difficiles c'est à dire que les familles
partagent au centre des cuisines
ouvertes et des points d'eau ils vivent
les familles vivent chacune dans des
chambres voilà les conditions de vie à
l'origine aujourd'hui c'est famille
n'ont plus rien elles ne veulent pas
partir de chez elles moi j'ai pu entrer
dans ces maisons ils vivent dans des
conditions extrêmement précaires ils ne
veulent pas partir et certains dorment
encore dans leur maison avec les murs
effondré il faut bien savoir qu'à
Marrakech évidemment ça a pas été la
ville qui a été la plus touchée il faut
savoir qu'à Marrakech il y a peu d'aide
en ce moment pourquoi parce que tout
aide et monopolisé sur les extérieurs
donc c'est toujours on va parler de
l'aide dans un instant si on va vous
dire pourquoi aussi vous allez me dire
un Jacques aussi là-dessus la France
exprimée sa solidarité bien sûr avec le
Maroc et le peuple marocain une cellule
de crise immédiatement été mise en place
et Emmanuel Macron a rapidement déclaré
que la France se tenait prête à aider au
premier secours et la le Maroc a accepté
l'aide de l'aide de 4 pays on vous dira
lesquels mais pas celle de la France on
parlera dans un instant
juste Jacques marine un séisme ce qu'on
peut rappeler ce que c'est oui c'est la
terre qui casse c'est l'écorce
terrestres qui se fragmente qui se
fracture alors plus cette fracture sur
une fracture longue plus le séisme et
puissant dans le cas de du Maroc c'est à
peu près 7 donc c'est à peu près une
faille de 50 km et les deux parties se
décale de 3 mètres alors toutes les bien
sûr toutes les maisons sont sur la
faille sont détruites bien évidemment
c'est déjà un séisme important ça se
déclenche comment on fait ça se
déclenche c'est que en fait il y a des
contraintes il y a des forces en fait il
y a des plaques lithosphériques des
plaques tectoniques qui bougent alors il
y a une plaque africaine une plaque
eurasienne les deux se rapprochent
Marrakech dans la nuit du vendredi 8 au
samedi 9
regardez dans le ciel
expliquez-moi en commentaire s'il vous
plaît merci
alors c'est c'est quoi en fait ça n'a
rien à voir c'est des c'est des lésions
qu'ils font des des couleurs
particulières un peu comme un peu comme
des aurores boréales quoi donc c'est
bien sûr artificielle mais ce n'est pas
du tout lié au séisme ça a été dit mais
c'était c'est faux d'accord est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir ce genre de séisme en
France alors la France c'est grand si on
prend les départements ultramarins oui
aux Antilles il y a eu des séismes très
important notamment Guadeloupe en 1843
il y a eu 2000 à 3000 morts qui ont
l'équivalent de ce qui s'est passé
malheureusement ici au Maroc sur la
métropole on va dire que le pays est
moyennement a faiblement sismique donc
il y a des régions qui ne risquent
quasiment rien notamment en
Île-de-France d'autres régions qui sont
plus jeunes géologiquement qui peuvent
être impactés notamment les Alpes moi je
suis grenoblois les Pyrénées la vallée
du Rhin etc et donc il y a eu des
séismes on va dire que tous les 10 ans
il y a un séisme Intuit de 5 ou un peu
plus là c'était 7 au Maroc et puis on va
dire que tous les 100 ans c'est six ou
plus donc la référence avec pour la
scène on a une crue centenal de 1910 on
a un séisme sentent mal de 1909 qui a eu
lieu à Lambesc près d'Aix-en-Provence
magnitude 6,2 6,4 qui a été 50 morts à
l'époque s'il se reproduisait ça
fonctionne en plus de morts il y a plus
de monde et donc on n'est pas à l'abri
d'un séisme meurtri en France une fois
par siècle une fois bien métropolitaine
sur Nice quand même oui la région PACA
est une région on va dire très concernée
parce que justement les séismes de
Lambesc a eu lieu près d'Aix-en-Provence
donc c'est la région la plus concernée
on va dire tout tour le militaire année
concerné donc mais sur le Maroc
l'Algérie l'Italie la Grèce l'Albanie la
Macédoine et puis le sud de la France
alors il y a nombreux pays qui ont
proposé bien sûr de l'aide au Maroc
c'est notamment le cas de l'Espagne du
Royaume-Uni de l'Inde de la Turquie du
Qatar des Émirats arabes unis de la
République tchèque bien d'autres le
Maroc a accepté l'aide de seulement 4
pays l'Espagne le Qatar la
Grande-Bretagne la Grande-Bretagne et
les Emirats Arabes Unis d'autres offres
pourraient être acceptées à l'avenir si
les besoins devaient évoluer ce qu'ils
ont dit pourquoi la proposition de la
France n'a pas été sélectionnée Jacques
il y a plusieurs contentieux politiques
entre les deux pays alors c'est un peu
complexe on va pas forcément rentrer
dans tous les détails mais il y a
notamment des prises de position au
sujet du Sahara occidental qui ne
plaisent pas du tout au Maroc il y a
l'affaire Pegasus il y a eu l'affaire
c'est une affaire d'écouter
c'est à dire que le Maroc aurait écouté
Emmanuel Macron Vienne société
israélienne et évidemment ça a créé une
immense défiance entre les deux pays qui
a encore sur le Maroc démon le Maroc des
membres bien entendu utiliser ce
logiciel espion et c'est vrai que ça a
vraiment tendu les relations entre les
deux pays et la réduction des visas
aussi entre le Maroc et la République
donc c'est très dommage parce que les
Français ont une très grande expertise
en matière d'intervention sur des sur
des terrains comme cela c'est arrivé
notamment en Turquie sur le grand séisme
en Turquie où les Français avaient
obtenu beaucoup de résultats ils sont
spécialistes en matière de
désincarcération notamment ils ont du
matériel que d'autres pays n'ont pas
forcément ou en tous les cas ils en
France on exploite ce matériel là depuis
très longtemps on a un très gros
savoir-faire et là il y a un grand
besoin dans des zones très reculées où
il y a pas de où il y a pas de chemin et
notamment dans le Atlas et c'est vrai
que c'est très dommage parce que la
France pourrait aider et concourir et
que la politique puisse prendre le
dessus sur l'aspect humain c'est quand
même dommage alors il y a de nombreuses
personnalités qui ont également apporté
leur soutien au Maroc en France c'est
notamment le cas des humoristes Amel
Debbouze Élie Semoun et bien sûr Gad
Elmaleh regardez
c'est catastrophique jamais de de
l'histoire de ma famille en tout cas on
a vécu une chose pareille et il y a
quand même il y a une très grosse très
grande angoisse en ce moment au Maroc on
est à gare face à cette situation et on
se demande comment comment être utile
mon cœur saigne et je ne peux qu'être
solidaire ça a dû s'écrouler comme des
châteaux de cartes et oui c'est c'est
déchirant déchirant la nouvelle très tôt
au réveil et puis c'est une réelle
tragédie beaucoup de tristesse et il
faut qu'on aide ces personnes aussi qui
sont en vie à reprendre la vie et c'est
pour ça que je prends la parole
essentiellement pour motiver en tout cas
et fédérer autour de cet appel aux dons
parce que c'est le nerf de la guerre
il y a aussi Achraf Hakimi également qui
réagi le footballeur et qui a demandé il
est très important d'aller donner votre
son voilà c'est si vous êtes
actuellement au Maroc c'est ce qui a
demandé achrafa Kimi aujourd'hui
jacquemarie donc ce qui inquiète le plus
je le vois à la sur les réactions des
gens qui nous écrivent c'est que il
pourrait avoir un deuxième séisme on
pourrait pas le prédire dans une semaine
dans deux jours dans on sait pas du tout
oui c'est assez classique ce qu'on
appelle les répliques la faille a bougé
mais elle va se réajuster donc pendant
les jours qui suivent il y a des
centaines de répliques plus ou moins
perceptibles on dit en général que la
règle c'est que la plus grosse des
répliques c'est un point de moins en
magnitude donc si c'est sept pour
des bâtiments qui sont déjà c'est ça
donc mais également il y a une autre
règle qu'on observe souvent cette
statistique tout ce que je dis bien
évidemment c'est que le troisième jour
il y a trois fois moins de risques de
réplique le troisième jour c'est
aujourd'hui c'est ça donc on va dire que
le temps joue pour marocain et pour nous
tous donc si on passe aujourd'hui il y a
moins de risque
sinon ça dure encore des semaines voire
des mois parce que c'est quand même été
très secoué les failles ont bougé tout
le temps que tout se restabilise ça va
prendre effectivement un certain temps
Jacques on a l'impression euh qu'on voit
de plus en plus de drame catastrophes
naturelles est-ce que c'est juste une
impression qu'on a ou est-ce que c'est
la réalité alors ce qui concerne les
catastrophes internes sur lié au globe
sur les volcans les séismes c'est c'est
faux c'est c'est une c'est pas l'arrêt
d'accord alors c'est vrai que c'est
catastrophes sont plus médiatisés c'est
d'ailleurs c'est très bien s'intéresse
les gens vous faites votre travail donc
les gens sont plus au courant mais on va
dire aux statistiquement il y a 50
éruptions par an dans le monde c'est
toujours ça depuis que je fais de la
volcanologie les séismes il y a 20
séismes de magnitude 7 dans le monde par
an alors que c'est en Alaska ou quand
c'est aucun chat cas il y a zéro mort on
en parle pas mais le séisme est aussi
puissant c'est ça d'accord voilà donc
c'est pas alors par contre les
catastrophes externes liées au climat
tout à l'heure vous parliez du GIEC ça
c'est autre chose bien
quand même là il y a eu la Turquie des
dizaines de milliers de morts puis là le
Maroc des milliers de morts est-ce que
ça veut dire qu'on est potentiellement
entré dans une phase où toutes les
plaques de la terre là sont si je puis
dire en ébullition et ce qu'on risque
partout des tremblements de terre alors
non c'est pas vrai et le nombre de morts
n'est pas totalement lié à l'intensité
du séisme si un séisme est en zone
habité et s'il est superficiel il va
faire des grosses etruptions si les
profonds ont inhabité donc on va dire il
y a un séisme en début d'année
assistance fin d'année ça reste aux
mesures c'est dramatique ce que vous
dites 58000 morts en Turquie ici presque
3000 au Maroc mais on va dire ça reste
normal au niveau statistique de la terre
de l'énergie de la terre
merci d'avoir été avec nous en tout cas
merci Jacques Marie d'avoir été là on
pense bien sûr très fort à nos amis
marocains oui Bernard quelque chose bon
moi je suis né au Maroc évidemment je
suis particulièrement bouleversé comme
comme Valérie et aussi nous tous ici
toute façon on pense très fort à eux je
voulais dire aussi que il y a peut-être
un grand concert en train de se préparer
avec tout un tas d'artistes et on va
essayer de merci à côté des fonds on va
se retrouver dans un instant encore
merci merci beaucoup